these charred window frames are some of
what's left of mate balsh hospital
after a fire swept through it burning at
least five patients to death
fire crews worked through the night to
put out the flames
of all i'd like to express my
condolences to the families of the
patients that died
it's four people three of which were
found carbonized and the fourth one they
tried to resuscitate
but to no avail
it's not clear what caused it but
there's anger over the third hospital
fire
in as many months protesters suspect
there's corruption
behind the lack of investment in aging
buildings
they want the president and the
ministers in charge to resign
after 31 years in which we paid taxes
and got nothing in return
not a single new hospital was built in
romania in 31 years
although we paid the money was stolen
from the romanian medical system
we want the resignation of those
responsible if things don't change
radically
romania's president promised to get
justice for the victims
the situation is somewhat repeating
itself we had a tragedy not long ago
there were smaller fires at other
hospitals and certainly the reasons are
diverse
they are under investigation the
investigations will bring to light what
happened
who is guilty and the guilty will be
sanctioned
but these promises may not be enough to
quell growing anger
mate hospital was built in the 1950s
and had been recently renovated even
before the covered pandemic
romania's health system had been
criticized over inefficiency
and politicized management this latest
fire is certain to put the government
under more pressure
to reform it barbara angopa al jazeera